[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
Today, we are going to learn
how to create a Google Compute
Engine virtual machine instance.
You can create a VM using
the Google Cloud Console,
the Google Cloud CLI, the
Google Cloud Platform API,
or client libraries in languages
such as C#, Go, and Java.
First, start with visiting
the VM Instances page
in the Compute Engine section.
Here, click on the
Create Instance button.
Before we proceed
further, decide
how you would like to
create the instance.
That is, you could choose
to create the new instance
from scratch, using an
existing template, a machine
image, or a ready-to-go solution
from Google Cloud Platform
Marketplace.
For now, we'll create an
instance from scratch.
Next, specify a
name for your VM.
Here are some naming
convention guidelines
that you need to follow.
The name should be 1 to
63 characters in length.
It must always start
with a lowercase letter.
And then it can be followed
by a combination of hyphens,
lowercase letters, and numbers.
It should not end with a hyphen.
We'll use the name
test-instance1.
Now we'll add a label
to the instance.
Labels help you group instances
related to a particular task
together.
If you would like to
group this instance,
add a key and a
value attached to it.
We will add the label
as "usage test,"
as this is a test VM for us.
Now choose a region
and zone for the VM.
Note region and zone for a VM
are permanent configurations
and cannot be changed
after a VM starts.
Let's create the instance
in us-central1 region
and us-central1-a zone.
Beside the machine
configuration for your VM,
based on your requirements
you could choose
from one of these options--
general-purpose,
compute-optimized,
memory-optimized, and
GPU-based machines.
Let's choose the
general-purpose E2 machine.
Now select the machine series,
machine type, number of CPUs,
CPU platform, amount of
RAM, and machine GPUs.
We'll choose any
2-medium type machine
with 2 vCPUs and 4 GB memory.
The CPU would be
automatically selected,
and we will not be adding
a GPU to this instance.
Next, if you wish to capture
or record this VM's screen,
then check the option "Enable
display device" on the machine.
We won't be enabling
this because we
don't have a requirement of
screen recording this VM.
If you want to deploy a
container on this instance,
you could walk through the
container configuration
settings for the instance.
For now, we aren't deploying
a container on this instance,
so we'll skip this.
In the Boot Disk
section, you need
to select the type and
size of the instance.
Note the default configuration
is a Debian image with 10 GB
persistent disk.
You can replace this with
public images, custom images,
snapshots, or existing disks.
For this demonstration, we will
use the standard Debian GNU
Linux 11 image with a
10 GB persistent disk.
If you want your applications
to invoke Google Cloud Platform
APIs, then you need to select a
service account in the Identity
and API Access section.
Choose a service account
that has the required
level of API access.
We will use a default Compute
Engine service account
with default type and level of
API access to ground to the VM.
Now let's move to
the Firewall section.
If you want to
allow HTTP or HTTPS
traffic for your instance, then
enable the "Allow HTTP traffic"
and "Allow HTTPS traffic"
setting checkboxes.
For our instance, we prefer
to enable both these options.
Finally, we are done with
specifying all configurations
for our VM instance.
Review the monthly
estimate for the VM
with the breakdown of items
being used and sustained
use discounts applied.
If you are happy, then click the
Create button and start the VM.
Congratulations.
The VM has been created
and is ready to use.
For more information
about creating VMs,
please refer to our
official documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]